[Música]
último debate presidencial de Cara a la
primera vuelta de las elecciones del
próximo domingo en Brasil un encuentro
que podría ser decisivo para los dos
principales candidatos el presidente
Yair bolsonaro y su rival el ex
mandatario Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien lo aventaja en las encuestas
Tenemos reporte
Ian vuelve a fortalecerse en aguas del
Atlántico y es nuevamente un huracán que
ahora amenaza a las costas de las
carolinas y Georgia el fenómeno devastó
el suroeste de Florida donde continúan
las labores de búsqueda y rescate el
presidente Joe byden advirtió que podría
tratarse de la tormenta más mortífera en
golpear el estado
en México el grupo interdisciplinario de
expertos independientes que sigue el
caso de la desaparición de los 43
normalistas de Ayotzinapa acusó a la
fiscalía de intromisión en la
investigación cuestionaron que se haya
solicitado la cancelación de 21 órdenes
de aprehensión que ya habían sido
libradas la noticia se da en el marco de
los 8 años del caso
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil porque los candidatos a la
presidencia se vieron cara a cara por
última vez de Cara a la primera vuelta
de las elecciones de este domingo un
encuentro clave para los dos principales
candidatos ya que las encuestas
continúan dándole una cómoda ventaja al
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
sobre el presidente Yair bolsonaro quien
Busca la reelección Valeria sacone con
los detalles
tensión y cruces de acusaciones en el
último gran debate electoral antes de la
cita del 2 de octubre los dos favoritos
el presidente revolucionario y la
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
se han enfrentado en varios momentos y
se han acusado recíprocamente de ser
mentirosos hay que recordar que Luna
tiene técnicamente un 50% de intención
de Voto mientras que evolucionaron tiene
un
36%, es decir Lula podría ganar Incluso
en la primera vuelta y por eso en los
últimos días hemos visto una campaña a
favor del voto útil por parte de
aquellos que temen que puede haber
disturbios en el caso de una derrota de
bolsonaro creo que destacar que en el
debate se ha habido muchas acusaciones
pero os he hablado poco de contenidos
hablan poco Los candidatos de lo que
quieren hacer con Brasil en el caso de
ganar concretamente Lula iba a desvelar
Cuál es su plano de gobierno a lo largo
del mes de septiembre pero su equipo de
campaña ha decidido no hacerlo con las
disculpas de que todavía están
recibiendo ideas y sugestiones por parte
de los electores en realidad Lula está
pidiendo un cheque en blanco a la
población basado en lo que él hizo
cuando era presidente entre 2003 y 2010
cuando Brasil se convirtió en la sexta
mayor Economía del mundo en el caso de
que gane en la primera vuelta tendrá que
explicar qué quiere hacer sobre todo
para reflotar la economía Mientras tanto
el ambiente en Brasil extenso el
Tribunal Superior electoral ha prohibido
que el día de las elecciones se
transporten armas y municiones lo que
dan idea de cómo está el clima en este
momento en el país más poblado de
América Latina
y la intención internacional está en el
estado de Florida en el sur de Estados
Unidos allí las autoridades comenzaron a
evaluar los daños dejados por el paso
del huracán Ian el presidente joeyden
Indicó que podría tratarse del huracán
más letal en la historia de Florida y
afirmó que visitaría la zona cuando las
condiciones lo permitan Mientras tanto
en terreno el gobernador ron de santis
dijo que están realizando una operación
de barrido para verificar número de
damnificados y víctimas fortalecido en
aguas del Atlántico y han que nuevamente
su huracán de categoría 1 ahora toma
rumbo hacia las costas de Georgia y las
carolinas
y han recuperado fuerza convertido
nuevamente en huracán ahora tienen la
mira las carolinas y al estado de
Georgia Mientras tanto Florida cuenta
sus heridas y se prepara para un conteo
doloroso
este podría ser el huracán más mortífero
en la historia de la Florida los números
aún no están claros pero estamos
escuchando los primeros informes de lo
que puede haber una pérdida sustancial
de vida la presencia del líder de la
Casa Blanca en la sede de la agencia
Federal para el manejo de emergencia
fima es el prólogo de una recuperación
que se anuncia larga y difícil
Mientras tanto en la Península de la
Florida el panorama es desolador tras
las marejadas ciclónicas y los vientos
sostenidos de más de 240 kilómetros por
hora los condados de Sarasota y
Charlotte uno de los más afectados
reportan sus primeros fallecidos con
cifras a un confusas y con tendencia al
alza el gobernador local ron de santis
informó sobre las labores de rescate que
se están llevando a cabo Incluso se negó
a dar una cifra probable de fallecidos
han habido reportes de cientos de
muertes en el condado Delhi tiene algo
que decir nada
de eso está confirmado creo que eso es
que hubo llamadas al 911 en el que las
personas dijeron Oye el agua está
subiendo a mi casa voy a subir al ático
pero estoy muy preocupado por supuesto
ahora se verificarán a esas personas
para tener Claridad al próximo día y que
los socorristas puedan ir a esos lugares
y determinar si las personas necesitan
servicios o pueden ser rescatados
hasta el momento las compañías locales
de Electricidad informaron que más de
2,6 millones de hogares y negocios en
Florida no contaban con servicio
eléctrico en las áreas tradicionalmente
turísticas ahora convertidas en zona de
desastre continúan las labores de
búsqueda y rescate con la ayuda de
embarcaciones y helicópteros
Cuba continúa en la oscuridad tras los
apagones causados por el huracán y han
después de su paso por la isla en la
capital la Habana solo se ha
restablecido el servicio de energía en
algunos barrios pero gran parte de los
11 millones de habitantes del país
Siguen sin electricidad recuerdo con las
autoridades Aunque ha habido Progreso
Aún se encuentran en las primeras etapas
de una recuperación compleja ya que ella
anda arribó cables de alta tensión
posteriormente si hay que hacer ya los
balances de generación carga no no
tenemos como como estaba sucediendo
antes de que ocurriera el paso del
huracán guía no teníamos capacidad
generación suficiente para cubrir la
demanda eso no ha cambiado se abre un
nuevo episodio en la desaparición de los
43 estudiantes de Ayotzinapa el grupo
interdisciplinario de expertos
independientes de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
denunció la intromisión y obstrucción de
la fiscalía del ejército mexicano en las
investigaciones sobre el caso y que
buscaría obstaculizar las pesquisas el
panel expertos cuyo mandato concluye
este 30 de septiembre también lamentó la
renuncia del fiscal especial del crimen
después de que la fiscalía general
cancelará sin Consultar los 21 órdenes
de arresto de las que 16 corresponden a
militares
desde el punto de vista de lo que está
sucediendo detrás del telón pero los
hechos concretos si es categóricamente
que se ha tratado de frenar Las
investigaciones que se han dado órdenes
de no judicializar inclusive sea órdenes
de no ir a audiencias que en un estado
de derecho
la fiscalía como ente autónomo no puede
tener más consideraciones que las
consideraciones judiciales probatorias Y
lograr condenas producto de esta
formalización o judicialización débil
del ex procurador Murillo caram se corre
el riesgo de que posteriormente no se
logre una condena no obstante existir
evidencia y prueba de la participación
del señor Murillo cara en la
construcción de la mal llamada verdad
histórica en Argentina las autoridades
evacuaron la casa rosada sede del poder
ejecutivo a raíz de una amenaza de bomba
que también pesaba sobre el Ministerio
de defensa donde estaba prevista la
llegada del presidente Alberto Fernández
los detalles nos los entregaba
previamente nuestro corresponsal natalio
kosori
bueno así es la información que primero
se conoció por medios locales es que
hubo unos llamados prácticamente
simultáneos al número de emergencias de
Argentina que es el 911
alertando sobre esta o avisando una
amenaza de de bomba o de explosivos en
la casa rosada en la casa de gobierno y
en el edificio del Ministerio de defensa
el Ministerio de defensa iba a
participar y participó de hecho el
presidente Alberto Fernández de un
evento una cena de cámara de día militar
allí la realidad es que yo me comuniqué
para para confirmar con la policía
federal y me dijeron que que se había
hecho el barrido que habían ido a
chequear el lugar y que tras el chequeo
dieron cuenta de que no había explosivo
vivió negativo a la búsqueda de
explosivos en el lugar de hecho este
este mismo día viernes más temprano por
la mañana mediodía hubo también una
amenaza de bomba en la ex escuela de
mecánica de la armada que era un centro
clandestino de detención durante la
dictadura y se convirtió en democracia
en años reci en un espacio donde
funcionan muchos este centros y
organismos de Derechos Humanos también
hubo que hacer un desalojo también en la
policía verificó y no encontró ninguna
explosivo no en términos de hipótesis de
que puede haber detrás de esto la verdad
que no hay hipótesis claras que me hayan
podido compartir es muy prematuro no es
la primera vez que ocurre este tipo de
llamados de amenazas en Argentina la
realidad es que no no suelen estar
acompañadas por hechos concretos de
atentados Pero bueno obviamente llaman a
una reacción por parte de los servicios
de seguridad
hasta que esta informativa en Francia 24
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]